je vais vous dire la vérité non mais moi
je n'ai aucun je vais vous dire la
vérité non mais jamais les extrêmes qui
est à diverses wade que j'avais une
attirance pour les hommes depuis
toujours parce que tous mes amis sont
bisexuels bon voilà et c'est vrai qu'un
saut un soir et voilà on y arrive mais
non mais si oui je m'en fous j'ai pas de
honte c'était en maillot de bain mais
didier n'ont pas de gym et non pas du
tout moi je vis des moments très
difficiles
un soir je passe un test fond je vois si
vraiment un homme mexique donc j'ai mis
un film pas unie a filmé pendant afrique
gay et j'ai baissé mon pantalon
si jamais il se passe quelque chose
alors peut-être que j'ai une référence
commune s'est rien passé j'étais sûre de
moi je ne suis donc pas gay l'étoile
assez fébrile en comptant il l'a
racontée en coulisses a dit oui c'était
vrai c'est les pas des autres mais moi
je me suis posé la question forcément je
suis pas attirée par les hommes
s'apprêtent tous mes amis sont
homosexuels donc voilà c'est tout c'est
tout est ce que tu veux faire le test
nous avons filmé à la maison et donc à
apprendre du tout aller voir voilà j'ai
fait ce test là parce que ma femme pense
que j'ai un dos et tout ça je viens chez
lui c'était j'étais un peu plus jeune
ségolène jeu toujours aussi bonne heure
et il me dit voilà mais je le dis rien
du tout en fait un nazairien dont il
était le regard c'est l'ironie n'est pas
de regardons pour l'amateur des bases
étaient tous les deux oui mais pas du
n'importe quoi mais non mais et en plus
il avait son fiancé à la maison et alors
là là il est doué mais il faudra
confirmer
[Rires]
non pas du tout
et
vous et jacuzzi avec miss n'ont rien
[Applaudissements]
à voir je lui ai fait beau à ceux des
régionales et je vous le dis
ici ce qui me doit ouais c'est le cas
merci réponse n'entend pas avant d'aller
à la prochaine soirée
iman savaient pas ils m'aident à me
voilà ça y est on y vient d'amitié
habitants mais nous ne nous est jamais
traversé l'esprit voilà de regarder avis
moi là non on respecte ses réflexes
liberto si besoin
à bagdad en tout cas qu'est castaldi
voulez vous raconte pas l'autre dossier
ah si
mélo 2002 mais c'est moi je vous moi je
moi je m'échappe j'adore jasta moi je
m'en fous je voudrais pas deux ans moi
je veux tout vous dire je n'ai aucun
problème d'abord d'abriel devant c'est
pas un délit c'est pas grave bien sûr
oui non mais c'est vrai qu'un jour
j'étais très enfants que j'ai montré mon
meilleur ami s'il voulait pas s'occuper
de moi il m'a dit tu es
[Applaudissements]
ah
là là et on fait
un peu pompette baignoire peine et m'a
dit tu es beaucoup trompé terreau pour
moi donc il s'est rien passé mais bon on
va coûter mais c'est mérité moitié n'ont
toujours rien passé mais c'était l'année
ou d'envoyer ses thématiques menton sexe
en érection à des noms prénoms peu
novateur à
jouer
mais on savait qu'on à l'antenne
à la une de partout dietemann n'y a pas
de honte ça vient pas d'eux n'en vient
pas de là
j'ai appris et bossi je pense de
nombreuses choses sur l'équipe pendant
ses effets
tu sais toujours pas qui tu aimes ça va
non tout va bien je vais très bien je
vais très bien j'ai aucun problème